[Music]
hello and welcome to devops pipeline
setup and creation using various tools
introduction session we will look at
what a pipeline is what is pipeline
creation and what are the various tools
available on the market to create a
working pipeline in a DevOps project so
what exactly is a pipeline a devops
pipeline is essentially your set up in a
software project that helps to deliver
continuous integration continuous
deployment and eventually finally
leading to continuous delivery of your
software project we will discuss
continuous integration continuous
deployment and what exactly do we mean
by continuous delivery in more detail
here so the idea behind creating a
pipeline is to be able to create a
repeatable and reliable system and be
able to continuously improve the process
of software development and delivery in
order to make your software delivery
from concept stage to your customer
faster the goal here is to enable a
constant flow of changes into production
using an automated process by including
various tools it's each of the steps so
this is how our software development
lifecycle pipeline typically looks you
have processes that must enable faster
feedback cycles and create a culture for
learning the architecture for your
software development lifecycle for the
software that you're working on should
be agile for change and should be
resilient to failure and you should be
able to take what you learn from what is
failing or what is not working back to
your process faster and make the
appropriate changes and continue with
the pipeline you need to have the
necessary technology that enables you to
implement a pipeline that helps you to
increase productivity and maximize the
impact of the software that you are
developing so for technology you should
have the right tools and the necessary
software that makes it possible for you
to create and SDLC pipeline you need an
appropriate robust infrastructure such
as servers cloud environments virtual
machines and various innovative
platforms that enable creation of
pipeline set up over pipeline working of
a pipeline and eventually deploying the
software that you are creating using a
pipeline into your production
environment and then on into an
environment that your users can access
and have permission to look at so to
begin with the developer writes the code
and places the code in the source code
repository from there it is checked out
and all the source code is integrated
the build is then created from the code
in a source code repository in various
unit tests system tests and functional
testing is done on the newly created
build and any issues that are found are
reported back to the developer of course
you also need to do a deployment of your
build into various environments such as
your testing environment your system
integration environment UAT or staging
then finally you get to do the security
and penetration testing once the build
is ready for production then your
production environment is created and
set up and the final build is deployed
for your end customer now these things
that we just discussed are typical steps
that we follow in an sdlc lifecycle for
our software development and delivery a
lot of these steps are done manually
manual steps make these less repeatable
more error-prone and more time-consuming
environment setups are long drawn-out
processes and build creation deployments
are very time consuming taking up team
member time throughout the entire
project and this is time that could be
better utilized on other more important
tasks or tasks that improve the overall
quality of the deliverable or increase
the functionality you're trying to
deliver to your customer now this is how
it would look if you were to deliver all
the DevOps SDLC steps using a pipeline
we still have our developer who is
placing the code into your source
control management system like git which
can be continuously polled using a
continuous integration system like
Jenkins that can run various tools like
maven or ant to create a build from the
code in your source code repository so
this can all be automated now in order
to validate the build you can integrate
your continuous integration server your
jenkins with tools like sonar or fortify
that help you with various validation
and quality checks on your bill
you can create various quality gates in
sonar that basically validates your
build is good to go into production and
on to your customer for consumption
you can also trigger various tests like
unit tests script tests or functional
tests and all your system tests using
various plugins that Jenkins provides
for different test tools like J unit J
behave for BDD testing you can even
trigger your performance test Suites and
integration tests Jenkins offers a lot
of plugins for various test tools and
test Suites even selenium and cucumber
test Suites can be triggered using your
Jenkins integration server next in order
for you to do your user acceptance
testing security penetration testing you
can integrate your J unit your selenium
your cucumber your sauce labs and
various testing frameworks with your
continuous integration server these can
automatically trigger the scripts on
various test suites that you need to run
against the build
continuous integration servers also help
you configure your production
environment you can integrate these with
tools like puppet and chef which are
configuration management tools and they
can help you setup your production
environment automate the creation and
setup of your production environment and
finally do your build deployment on the
environment now this could be a VMware
environment it could be an Amazon AWS
cloud environment it could be a
Rackspace or open stock so looking at
this diagram we have essentially
converted all the manual steps from
deployment to build build a testing test
to UAT
and finally to your production
deployment using various tools so
essentially we've created a software
integration software deployment and
software delivery pipeline using various
tools available in the DevOps toolkit
now here is a snapshot view of the
various tools available in a DevOps SDLC
pipeline these tools have been
categorized by the different phases of
your project now here you see the
various source control repositories next
you see various databases and then you
see a whole bunch of build tools here
you have your Jenkins in bamboo and
Travis these are your continuous
integration servers
these are various deployment tools these
are various configuration management
tools here you have your
containerization tools here we see the
various cloud environments where your
software can be deployed over here you
can see various monitoring tools various
error logging tools and various security
tools so you can see there are a lot of
tools available and depending on what
your software requirement is or what
kind of project you're working on you
can select any of these tools in any of
these categories that fit your
requirements Hey
want to become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here